hi I'm Oscar Isaac I play pode Ameren hi
I'm des Ridley and I play right hi I'm
John boyega play FINA hi I'm Kelly Marie
Tran hopefully Rose tikka hi I'm Keri
Russell I play zouri hi I'm Naoki and I
play Jana hello I'm Anthony Daniels I
play c-3po my name is Richard II grant
and I play allegiant general pride my
name is Jana sorta MA and I play a hairy
guy called Chewbacca as MFL Billy Dee
Williams and I play Lando Calrissian
we're gonna take a test to see if we are
on the light side or the dark side first
things first
pick a crystal color for your lightsaber
red blue green purple orange or black
I'm gonna go with black because I just
haven't seen a bad lightsaber because I
like it
I'm gonna go red because that's my
finger cut off black because green
because my favorite color for that
orange I'm gonna choose black because I
don't think anybody hasn't black
lightsaber do that did you ever see a
man lies over not yet not yet well you
will now because I'm choosing black I'm
gonna go with orange I'm going with
purple pick an iconic Star Wars quote I
find your lack of faith disturbing
the force be with you always do or do
not there is no try
why you stuck-up half-witted
scruffy-looking nerf-herder
I'm just a simple man trying to make my
way in the universe
and lastly this is how Liberty dies with
thunderous applause that's a strong
quote yeah yeah because sounds the least
Star Wars details I'm gonna go for do or
do not there is no traffic light yoga
yeah my dad actually says that to me a
lot I'm just a simple man I plan to make
my way in the universe I find your lack
of faith disturbing oh that's mean pick
a character from Star Wars the options
are c-3po Chewbacca r2d2 Jabba the Hutt
JA Jar Binks and a poke into someone
better big picture Baca I think you
might have to okay I'm cornbread I
picked Chewbacca I'm switching to Jabba
the Hutt I've been to choose janja oh I
can't stairs oh that's me pick something
worth fighting for and the options are
family power free speech education
self-preservation
money family family family family so
money right this finally for fun pick a
baby Yoda baby Yoda sipping bra baby
Yoda in a spacecraft baby Yoda in
trouble baby Yoda using the force
baby Oda cruising by in a carriage the
baby Yoda looking cute baby Yoda
cruising down into carriages for me baby
you date using the for sitter baby
you're a sippin can I go with broth I
went broth I said that baby out of a
sipping tea I've done this yeah I picked
baby Yoda in trouble cuz no one else's
there we go but just like this must be
wrong this Moss vehicle hm
turn aside mine too it's a glitch is a
double exerts I've got the light side
you've got the lights I have the light
side
radiative you got there
so you're on the dark side of the force
look at it this way this means that
you're ambitious and strive for power
which isn't always a bad thing except in
this case in this case it is you got the
right side you're selfish compassionate
and you strive for infinity if you use
your powers for good and you do your
best to do what's right and fair at
times you're tempted to be a little
selfish bias attract time for but at the
end of the day you do what's best for
all those qualities
[Laughter]
[Music]